Newton had the impostor syndrome he said
you're kidding me Newton he was like cuz
Newton was kind of a prick Newton had a
huge ego he was not kind to his friends
he tortured people as the master of the
mint or he had them tortured tortured
people yeah he was physically tortured
people he was responsible he was like
the exe he was responsible for the
equivalent of the IRS in in England so
people would cheat they would scrape
down pennies they that's right read this
he was the master of the mint it was
called yeah that's right I forgot about
this alist he he was an amazing guy but
he was kind of a prick and he had
impostor syndrome as well so he had
imposter Sy now who could he have
imposter syndrome about you might wonder
and if you read his writings do you know
what Isaac Newton the creator of
calculus the uh first- person understand
universal gravitation discovered laws of
Optics do you know what his biggest
accomplishment according to him was what
he died of Virgin yeah that was a weird
one right yeah I was going to bring that
up he was celibate you know why why
because there's only one way that he
could emulate his hero his the person
before whom he felt the impostor
syndrome and who was that that was Jesus
Christ oh boy so he wanted to be
Christlike he wanted to emulate Christ
and the only way he could do it he
couldn't like fast or I don't know he
couldn't bapti walk on water he couldn't
turn water into one he couldn't turn
loaves into fishes or whatever Jesus
also did but he could die cell it and
that's who he had imposters are you sure
he just didn't was like an excuse for he
didn't like sex I don't know I mean it
sounds nutty because like how do you
figure that out when you're like 14 15
years old you know you're young and full
of hormones and you've made this
decision to be like Jesus yeah he sounds
insane he definitely was he was not like
you would want to hang out with G if you
met want to hang out with him too yeah
know for a little bit just to see what
it's like so when you win the Nobel
Prize you go there and what is what is
the Commandment about idol worship it's
that you shall make no Guild
golden Graven like engraved images so
who is that do you know who that is uh
Albert Noble yeah it's Alfred Nobel
that's right Al and you know he invented
dynamite uh and he he also died he died
never having been married I don't know
if he was celibate or H so he was never
married um but he uh he established his
when you win it you literally the king
of Sweden comes up to you and you must
bow down to him and he puts the Gilded
Graven image on your head so for all the
you know trappings and all the 90% of
National Academy members who do not
believe actively profess a belief in God
this can become at some level of
religion and it's a kosher one it's okay
to worship right well the unattainable
for that that's maybe perhaps attainable
to a very select few is always the thing
that people are chasing after especially
like high Achievers that's right but
many many that I know that get there do
have impostor syndrome including MMA
world champions like some of them they
get there like this isn't n real this
can't be real I can't be the man cuz
they've set this up their whole life and
also it's they look you can get to the
promised land but you can't stay in it
how many baseball teams have won the uh
World Series year after year forever I
mean even the Yankees haven't done that
even your BX haven't done that right
they're not mine okay fine um but for me
as a young kid this is this is what I
aspired and actually as an adult I
wanted to win this basically at all cost
this became my but it was acceptable
because people told me you know like if
you discover these waves of gravity
manifest in the cosmic background
radiation that I study you're guaranteed
to win the Nobel Prize and it became an
obsession to me as well as being
scientifically interesting to be a part
of there are very few projects that are
eligible to win a Noble Prize let alone
that like can win it but but for me it
was kind of an added Dimension that came
with it and that was you know like the
normal kid might have it with sports and
her dad or or or maybe the other way
around with your when you're a dad you
might treat your kids like that like oh
you think you could take me on or
whatever like um and so for that that
was the main source of driving impetus
for my personal quest to get this
particular Idol in my life that's wild
are you aware of uh Ronald Mallet do you
know who he is no he is uh I believe
he's out of the University of
Connecticut he studies time travel and
he became obsessed with time travel
after his father died when he was a
young boy cuz he felt like if he worked
hard enough he could develop a time
machine and go back can save his
father it's why it's literally a
Spider-Man origin story exactly this guy
has been dedicated his life to finding
uh a working model of a time machine and
I think uh was it uh Kurt godell like
how do you say his name gerle it's that
weird yeah how do you say it what's
girdle ger it's like people let's say
van go and now it's really van excuse
you um but he developed a working model
but it it just required something like
the size of the of the solar system no
you're right I don't know how you know
that but yeah he had a spiraling he had
a rotating Cosmos where you could have
what are called World lines you could
have your just like you could walk
around the surface of the Earth and if
you go in the same direction eventually
you'll come back to where you started in
the if the universe was somehow rotating
in the way that he envisioned it you
could have it end up on a on a time
where you began from the beginning yeah
see that traveler life like light Tim
like curve wild girdle is interesting
because he he and Einstein were buddies
um back at the institute for Advance
study like I don't know if you saw
Oppenheimer bud I haven't seen it yet oh
you should see it I don't go to the
movies I do go to the movies I saw
barbie yeah did your
girls everything's a goddamn culture War
I know that's what I love about
astronomy no one ever freaking wakes up
and says see that Comet over there I
[__] that's a republican there's
there's there's a Democrat asro now it
also it makes you're studying things
that are so immense and so spectacular
that it makes all this stuff seem like
nonsense this stuff that people fill
their days up with complaining about a
[__] Barbie movie Jesus Christ